via the eyes they say they are united
even if their home city of dresden isn't
these teenagers from the Zemba high
school took on the challenge of
producing a film about how to make
dresden more multicultural in the wake
of the migration crisis it's been a
hotbed of anti-immigrant tension high
design fee dimension lot of people are
saying the topic of refugees is old news
who would still be interested in that
but it's still a huge issue every Monday
people take to the streets to protest
against the fact that the city is taking
in refugees they're scared and we wanted
to take a stand against that sort of
thing of obeah tithing is a Fremen
frankerz code sets I'm crisis lips to
get their message across in the film
they presented their ideas on
multiculturalism and acted out scenes to
confront the negative attitudes towards
migrants they've seen in their city it
was the teenagers first film and they
say making it was tougher than expected
they worked on it in their free time as
well as in their school ethics class but
interviewing a Syrian refugee family was
the biggest learning experience for the
group they found out firsthand about the
difficulties that migrants face in
Dresden there are lots of problems one
problem is the letters from the job
centre no one understands those letters
and there's the problem of paquita
[Applause]
pegida is a right-wing political
movement that has been marching every
monday in dresden for over two years the
group says it's concerned about the
so-called islamization of german society
this is the church behind the
competition the iconic phone kiya bombed
towards the end of World War two and
rebuilt as a symbol of Germany's
reunification it's in this spirit that
the church asked schools to come up with
ideas for a peaceful multicultural
society casillas dcl in beckley lips is
discarded you comin of this year's
competition is that young people in
particular grappled with these ideas
since they are the ones responsible for
shaping the future p a mouth and a nose
it's the girls from Zemba high school
rose to the challenge
they're optimistic that their ideas will
take root in Dresden the Antoine
Francois a lot of Amazon las of our arm
it's never motivated by the hope that
our work on this topic could make a few
people maybe just two or three think
about the topic more and that maybe that
can change things vergon can after
taking part in the competition this team
has a clear idea of what they want for
the city's future mutual understanding
tolerance and diversity